here you are at that point in your
career five years ago right before deal
or no deal right you're going out and
doing stand-up gigs right it's not
satisfying to you because it's not like
the great days when you were doing right
and you were gonna quit deal or no deal
hits the first day you go in to do deal
or no deal do you even know what you're
doing did you have a philosophy yeah
i'll tell you what i did okay so i took
the job and every day i'm cursing myself
and i'm going this is going to be
embarrassing this is going to be
horrible right and uh i figure you know
what i'll play it like groucho marx i'll
try to be funny and i'll try to play off
people i do that in my act i'll be i'll
improvise and i have all these ideas and
i'll never forget it it's like it's like
clear as day
i had all these ideas and then you know
i don't know if you remember that like
the first episode i start in the vault
and it was very dramatic and i know that
you know there's 26 cases each of these
cases holding amount of money one's got
a million dollars and as i'm walking and
talking and then i go out and somebody
can end up changing their life forever
just by asking one question
deal or no deal and the lights come up
and the crowd roars and i'm there and
i'm in the middle of this weird world
and then
i call on the first contestant and i'll
never forget her and she comes up and i
say tell me a little bit about yourself
and i've got all these great jokes and
uh
you know and and uh and she tells me you
know i have three children and the
children are sitting right there i see
these little kids sitting right there
and i have a husband and we've never
owned a home and we're paying rent and
we're in debt and we have no insurance
and i'm going i don't want this [ __ ]
responsibility right you don't want her
to lose well no i don't i want her to
win i don't i don't want her right so i
don't want to i feel like if i distract
her if i try to be funny if she chooses
the wrong case i'm going to [ __ ] this
woman's life forever yeah yeah i don't
want to stop with the jokes let's get
down a bit so i had no jokes you know so
right away i just looked into her eyes
because it just became about me and her
and and that's why even you know people
started making fun of my cadence and
they made fun of me on snl because i i
would go okay the offer is
35
000
that could help you yes i wonder if you
have people here on the radio who are
just in in a daze you know
you know they're they're glazed over
these people are in a tv studio there's
20 cameras around they're trying to talk
sense to them right now i'm going 35
000
and i you have no money remember that
right
chances are you're not gonna win and
they always got mad at me because i
would go you know that do you want to
take the deal or do you want it which is
a guarantee or do you want to take a
chance a chance a dumb chance at a
million dollars and
and that was and that was the thing and
that's because and people kind of tuned
in to the fact that i wasn't doing too
many jokes because i got so neurotic
that these people could have blown it if
you became a richard dawson type who sat
there and you're kissing the guests and
you're carrying on and all that the
thing i liked how you handled it is that
you went in and you became a game show
host if i'm watching a game i don't need
jokes i want the game well yeah but that
just came out of my neurosis